die politik schaut ratlos auf die bilder
der heftigen corona proteste jeden
montagabend so auch am gestrigen abend
immer mehr menschen sind da auf den
straßen in immer mehr städten und so sei
es eben diesmal aus eskaliert ist die
lage am palm in rostock hat die polizei
die demo aufgelöst und ist dann brutal
angegriffen wurden flaschen und steine
sind geflogen feuerwerkskörper dass das
was wir hier sehen ist das corona
deutschland und darüber sprechen wir
jetzt hier im studium mit unserem bild
politik chef jan schäfer schönen guten
tag
diese bilder ich habe schon gesagt die
sind zu einem ritual geworden in corona
deutschland jeden montagabend an vielen
anderen wochentagen auch und die politik
hat das im blick sagt sie hat dieses
problem erkannt die heftigen
auseinandersetzungen dort auf den
straßen seit vielen monaten trotzdem
gibt es immer mehr zulauf und trotzdem
radikalisiert sich diese szene immer
weiter ja der chef des
bundesverfassungsschutzes hat sich
jüngst geäußert thomas handwagen und er
hat auch gesagt wir sehen dort eine neue
szene die sich radikalisiert die gar
nichts mehr zu tun hat mit dem
klassischen rechts links schema sondern
das sind mehr oder weniger staatsfeinde
und er hat auch gesagt überraschend mit
welcher aggressivität dort einiger muss
immer sagen einige auch gegen die
polizei vorgehen also auch gegen jene
die den staat eigentlich verteidigen
gegen gewalt also eine neue radikale
szene bildet sich heraus vieles
entscheidet sich ja an der impfpflicht
und die ist schwierig ein zu finden sich
die politik gar nicht eigentlich immer
stellt sich die frage gäbe es diese
diskussion ich würde man sagen also
einführung der allgemeinen im pflicht
ist jetzt erstmal vom tisch glaubst du
dadurch würde sich die lage beruhigen
das glaube ich schon in gewisser weise
denn wir sehen ja dass die zahl
derjenigen die protestiert auch
zugenommen hat parallel zu der debatte
über die impfpflicht die wir ja seit
oktober eigentlich haben nach der
bundestagswahl ging es los und seitdem
sehen wir eine deutliche zunahme an
teilnehmerzahlen aber auch an
demonstrationen insgesamt im gesamten
bundesgebiet das bedeutet ganz klar da
gibt es eine parallelität unsere
reporter waren bundesweit am gestrigen
abend im einsatz und haben aus ganz
deutschland diese bilder mitgebracht von
den corner ab testen
skeptiker und gegner querdenker besorgte
bürger
die montagsspaziergänge
proteste gegen die staatlichen corona
maßnahme einige dieser demonstrationen
sind bei der polizei angemeldet zu
anderen wird nur über messenger dienste
aufgerufen aber wer sind diese menschen
die sich als das volk und die
unterdrückte mehrheit bezeichnung berlin
laut polizei demonstrieren gestern abend
tausende gegen die korona maßnahmen der
truppe zieht vom alexanderplatz richtung
brandenburger tor geimpft oder nicht
gemeinsam gegen die impfpflicht ist auf
transparenten zu lesen nur wenige
menschen tragen maske die stimmung
aufgeheizt
münster
in münster ist die polizei heute mit
einem großaufgebot vor ort denn hier
marschieren ungefähr 700 demonstranten
durch die innenstadt und im mittelpunkt
des projekts steht natürlich die
impfpflicht aber wenn man sich hier um
hört dann stellt man überrascht fest
dass einige der demonstranten sehr wohl
geimpft sind es geht den menschen halt
so viel mehr darum dass sie selber
bestimmen wollen ob sie sich impfen
lassen oder nicht und deshalb ziehen die
menschen heute friedlich ungefähr fünf
kilometer richtung unserer innenstadt
deutschlandweit demonstrieren
zehntausende menschen gegen korona
maßnahmen und eine mögliche impfpflicht
die polizei schätzt die zahl in dieser
nacht auf mehr als 70.000 die proteste
werden von polizei und vereinzelt auch
immer wieder von gegendemonstrationen
begleitet versammlungen in cottbus
werden aufgelöst weil die polizei keinen
versammlungsleiter feststellen kann oder
weil kein mund nasen schutz getragen
wird man ein wir befinden uns hier in
mannheim auf dem thunplatz das ist nicht
weit weg vom zentrum der stadt
auf einer angekündigten kundgebung von
impfgegnern das wurde mit 200
teilnehmern hier angemeldet sondern sie
sind auch nicht viel mehr oder eher
vielleicht weniger gekommen die
kundgebung die besteht außen vertreten
wird muss sie gespielt alles läuft es
dann ganz friedlich ab hexenkessel
mecklenburg vorpommern aufgeheizte
stimmung in der rostocker innenstadt an
zwei kreuzungen fährt die polizei mit
wasserwerfern auf
eingekesselte demonstranten proteste
auch in freiberg in sachsen auch hier
aufschrei gegen die impfpflicht
die demos verlaufenden größtenteils
friedlich
die menschen die wir sehen sie in
alltäglich aussieht ist keine
nazis oder
linksgerichtete menschen ganz normale
leute wir versuchen mal weiter zu fragen
warum sie hier sind was ist ihre
motivation
ich möchte eigentlich darauf aufmerksam
machen dass die gesundheit einfach auch
eine persönliche entscheidung ist
und ich wirklich die freiheit auch
möchte und darauf besteht sie selber zu
entscheiden was ich damit tun wie ich
tue mit was ich tue und mich einfach in
die schuhe bestimmen lassen immerhin ich
bin aus dem medizinischen bereich und
ich habe eine gewisse kenntnis drüber
und die kompetenz muss man mir einfach
zugestehen selber wenn meine gesundheit
zu entscheiden das ist im grunde alles
aber wir sind hier weil meine ganzen
maßnahmen nicht zufrieden sind ganz
einfach das was jeder eigentlich sagt
dass mir das einfach übertrieben finde
es gibt keine keine basis dafür was die
ja was hier abgezogen wird und wir sind
einfach damit unzufrieden ganz einfach